good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-294 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
there are no special standard
containment procedures on file or item
scp-294 however only personnel of
security clearance level 2 or higher are
allowed to interact with it see document
scp-294 a scp-294 is currently being
stored in the second floor personnel
break room and is monitored by two
guards of security clearance level three
at all times
description item scp-294 appears to be a
standard coffee vending machine the only
noticeable difference being an entry
touchpad with buttons corresponding to
an english QWERTY keyboard upon
depositing $0.50 u.s. currency into the
coin slot the user is prompted to enter
the name of any liquid using the
touchpad upon doing so a standard 12
ounce paper drinking cup is placed and
the liquid indicated is poured 97
initial test runs were performed
including requests for water coffee beer
and soda non consumable liquids such as
sulfuric acid wiper fluid and motor oil
as well as substances that do not
usually exist in liquid state such as
nitrogen iron and glass and each one
returned to success test runs with solid
materials such as diamond f failed
however as it appears that scp-294 can
only deliver substances that can exist
in a liquid state
it is of note that after approximately
50 uses the machine would not respond to
further requests after a period of
approximately 90 minutes the machines
seem to have restocked itself it is also
interesting to note that many caustic
liquids that would have eaten through a
normal paper cup seemed to have no
effect on the cups dispensed by the
machine testing is ongoing as suggested
scp-294 was moved to the second floor
personnel break room as a money-saving
venture following incident 290 401
guards were stationed at the item at a
security clearance became necessary to
interact with it document scp-294 8
regarding incident 294 1 on August 21st
2005 agent Joseph attempted to use item
scp-294 to obtain coffee during his
allocated break time at 9:30 a.m. at the
request of agent to see what it would do
requested a cup of joe from the item
moments after confirming the selection
agent joseph began to sweat profusely
and complained of dizziness before
collapsing after moving the unconscious
agent to the infirmary
the medical team recovered the contents
of the cup dispensed by item scp-294 a
combination of blood tissue and other
bodily fluids testing revealed the DNA
sequence of the biological material
dispensed by a CP 294 matched that of
agent page it made a complete recovery
after four weeks of rest and intravenous
hydration x-rays and cat scans showed no
further signs of injury that was
released both agents were reprimanded
additional security measures for scp-294
have been recommended
addendum scp-294 F after reviewing
documentation on scp-294 suggested
testing a CP 294 ability to retrieve
specific liquids from a distance
addendum scp-294 H with the overseeing a
bullfight a cup of SCP 75 secretion was
used as input the product was proven to
be the requested liquid and the cup was
able to successfully contain the
material however the report for incident
o 75 seven was acknowledged two hours
after the test see addendum SCP 75 M a
containment procedure breach had
occurred exactly the same time this test
was taking place
waking SCP 75 to its active stage it was
able to secrete an amount of basic
solution equal to the capacity of a
coffee cup before emergency containment
procedure was applied and it was
rendered passive the liquid was not
found in post incident investigation
addendum scp-294 eye researcher punched
in requests for cup of gold the machine
dispensed a cup of molten gulp
researcher requested similar precious
materials with the same result
addendum scp-294 j researcher punched in
from a safe range request for cup of
anti water the machine hummed briefly
then displayed out of range on entry pad
it is theorized that scp-294 has a
limited range of collection and cannot
reach into alternative universes or
dimensions addendum scp-294 came
researcher punched in requests for
diamond scp-294 briefly hummed then
displayed out of range on entry pad
scp-294 gives this result for all solid
substances as diamond is a solid
crystalline form of carbon it appears
that the machine will not dispense
liquid carbon as this does not result in
diamon when a cup of carbon was
subsequently punched in the machine
dispensed a cup of liquid carbon scp-294
was immune to the damaging effects of
the dispensed liquid addendum scp-294 M
testing for range of scp-294 capacity
for retrieval has been initiated a
unique compound has been formulated
composed of undisclosed ratios brand
bleach brand Cola ME TRX powder and
garam masala the fluid was created and
placed at a sealed container 25 metres
away from a CB 294 when requested the
fluid was dispensed an equal amount of
the mixture was no longer present in its
original container addendum scp-294 O
one researcher under observation of
level 4 personnel heed in a request of
the best drink I've ever had
scp-294 dispensed a fluid similar in
appearance to Cola the researcher
identified it as a mixed drink he
recalls having in a bar during his
bachelor party and was convinced it was
the best drink did not know what
ingredients were in the drink besides
rum and cola further tests are scheduled
to ascertain how a CP 294 gathers
information
addendum scp-294 o1a under the same
conditions agent the best drink I've
ever had scp-294 delivered a dark fluid
topped with a white foam which was later
identified as Vienna lager
the cup was printed with a color picture
of five men and two women drinking beer
on a beach it was one of them in his
briefing agent confirmed his favourite
drink ever was a Vienna lager he
consumed at the beach with his friends
it has now been confirmed that scp-294
has the ability to directly gather
information from someone's mind in order
to comply with the given conditions
addendum scp-294 q1 subject keyed the
perfect drink the machine dispensed a
cup containing an odorless lavender
liquid after drinking the liquid subject
appeared to go into shock subject later
committed suicide leaving a note which
read I'm sorry but at this point
everything's just one big letdown
requesting such a drink again is highly
discouraged none of the components of
the drink have yet been identified
addendum 290 41 subject keyed in the
something Cassie will lay the device was
hurt to hum for about three seconds
before dispensing an empty cup printed
on this side of the cup was an image of
a traditional soda fountain glass filled
with something Brown and topped with
whipped cream upon introduction to SCP
85 it was identified by her as a
chocolate banana milkshake and judged
delicious addendum scp-294 w researcher
keyed in a request for a cup of music
scp-294 produced a clear sparkling fluid
that tasted vaguely alcoholic following
ingestion subject reported feeling and
not hearing a continuous rhythm and
demonstrated the ability to move and
even dance with a certain fluidity that
he had not previously shown testing on
other abstract concepts is continuing
addendum scp-294 a bee during a mass
security breech agents requested a cup
of pertinent medical knowledge while
taking shelter inside the second floor
break room of the four agents in the
room agent was the only one who was not
injured as CP 294 poured a cup of clear
green liquid following the ingestion of
this substance it began mending other
agents wounds in a manner consistent
with foundation medical training agent
no longer has the medical training that
the liquid provided and other attempts
to recreate the effect have failed the
agent has speculated that this event was
an emergency measure taken by the object
to ensure self-preservation
addendum scp-294 AC doctor requested my
life story from a CP 294 scp-294 made
humming noises and shook violently for
approximately three minutes before
providing a highly viscous opaque black
liquid upon consumption doctor reported
that he remembered everything that it
ever happened to him following this test
doctor entered his office and returned
48 hours later with a 538 page
autobiography addendum scp-294 ad
researcher produced request consisting
solely of the phrase surprised me device
produced an opaque cup containing normal
water later determined to have been
heated to approximately 200 degrees
Celsius upon receiving vibration from
transport the contents of the cup turned
into steam violently spraying boiling
water in a two meter radius
addendum scp-294 AF researcher produced
request for blood of Christ scp-294
vibrated and produced the message hey
kam calyx Sangu is may then produced a
paper drinking cup containing
approximately 0.12 litres of red grape
wine
addendum scp-294 AG researcher produced
requests for cup of Smilodon blood cup
of passenger pigeon blood and cup of
thomas jefferson's blood and received
three out of range errors addendum
scp-294 aah
a d-class personnel with IQ of 99 and
low curiosity scores was given written
instructions about what to request the
d-class personnel produced a request for
blood of Canis lupus and received a cup
of liquid subsequently identified as
wolf blood the d-class personnel next
produced a request for saliva of Equus
ferus caballus and received a cup of
liquid subsequently identified as horse
saliva the d-class personnel next
produced a request for urine a fascicle
arctas cinereous and received a cup of
liquid subsequently identified as koala
urine the d-class personnel next
produced a request for cerebrospinal
fluid of fall burrow Me's Patterson and
received a cup of liquid currently
undergoing analysis it is to be noted
that fo burrow me spatter Sony went
extinct during the late miocene epoch
approximately eight million years ago
addendum scp-294 AI dr. king produced a
request for a cup of room-temperature
superconductor and received a cup of
apple juice with seeds floating in it
addendum scp-294 AJ dr. Menchu produced
request for couple of d15 1839 s
leukemia and received a cup of fluid the
fluid was microscopically examined and
found to contain leukemic blast cells
which were a genetic match to D 15 1839
a second request for cup of d15 1839 s
leukemia resulted in an out of range
error d 15 1839 was subsequently found
to be free of leukemia however within 15
days the leukemia had recurred other
a-c-p 294 experiments are currently
awaiting approval you can look forward
to a future lecture with a lot more
experiments I know you guys love that
right I think that about does it for
today thank you very much for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
good bye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to slump god Justin day John Porter
fluffy Pierce M Hamlin white crew beware
600 my archive curator neck tie verbal
Kody tench
cheese whip depp's McGee an oblong dish
boy if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you